from twigs to electrical toothbrushes
humans have been cleaning our teeth
since the ancient Egyptians in 5000 BCE
but what if you just straight-up stopped
brushing your teeth at all for the rest
of your life within minutes of stopping
the food debris and moist environment
from your saliva creates an ideal
environment for bacteria to survive
streptococci is one of the most common
bacteria found in our mouth and it's
normally not harmful
until it metabolizes sugar or protein
from food debris but after a full day
these bacteria would have already
produced significant amounts of plaque
from sugars plaque is the slimy layer of
biofilm that you can feel on your teeth
when you accidentally forget to brush
sometimes and this plaque actually helps
the bacteria adhere to your teeth which
allows them to produce even more plaque
creating a cycle of bacteria and plaque
build up after a week all this build-up
will cause some pretty serious bad
breath not to mention that the plaque
begins to harden and form tartar that
lead to your teeth appearing yellow at
this point you're also causing
significant damage to tooth enamel as
the bacteria break down sugar to produce
lactic acid enamel is the hard
mineralized outer layer of the tooth and
once it breaks down you can't make any
more after a month your decaying teeth
will form cavities these holes in your
teeths get deeper and deeper if left
untreated leading to gingivitis an early
form of gum disease this is because the
immune system attacks your gums and
teeth in response to the bacteria build
up your cavities will fill up with pus
which is a protein-rich fluid filled
with dead white blood cells and your
gums will be extremely sensitive at this
point turning red when you touch it and
bleeding with any significant pressure
after an entire year of neglect
you now have periodontitis the inner
layer of the gum and bone are broken
down by enzymes and pull away from the
teeth to form pockets which only further
allow collected food breeze and bacteria
to gather this causes the immune system
to go into overdrive and destroys your
gums and
comments resulting in advanced
periodontitis where your teeth become
loose and begin to fall out any longer
and the issues can spread beyond your
mouth and into your blood causing
inflammation throughout your organs and
increasing the likelihood of erectile
dysfunction a head and neck cancer
chronic heart disease and even dementia
development combined your lack of
brushing with a poor diet high in
processed foods and especially sugar
which is much more common now than early
Homo sapiens would have experienced and
you have a much more accelerated
breeding ground for bacteria putting
your whole body's health at risk brush
your teeth kids thank you guys for
watching if you have any burning
questions
naming questions that you want us to
answer leave it in the comments below
and we'll try to tackle it this year
seriously let us know what you want to
see we'll make it
okay make sure you're following us on
Instagram and Twitter and make sure you
subscribe to this channel for new
science videos every Thursday ok we'll
see you next week yes